welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the brand new Marvel's
trailer Brie Larson is back as Captain
Marvel and we're also seeing the big
screen debut of photon and Ms Marvel in
case you missed that show it's centered
heavily around Kamala Khan getting one
half of the Naga bands that we see
throughout this teaser first introduced
in the Captain Marvel Comics this
allowed the titular character to swap
places with Rick Jones that idea of body
swap is very much been brought across
here with the three protagonists
constantly switching places with each
other we see this in the introduction of
the teaser and we start off in space at
the saber base
Captain Rambo
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury
hello
[Music]
is this an Avengers test where's Captain
Rambo
[Music]
foreign
Marvel of their acronyms and saber is
its own one Shield were of course
revealed to be Hydra and sword had their
own issues with Hayward going haywire
according to the plot synopsis Enemy by
mamamo from streamer saber is now taking
over everything and the space station
itself even looks somewhat like a sword
and shield I believe that this is
actually based on the Peak from the
comics which was a satellite station
used to monitor Earth activity now why
don't we find Nick Fury so I'm guessing
he survived secret Invasion spoiler
alert
and Nick has clearly been monitoring
things from space which is why we left
him on a scroll ship at the end of far
from home I'm guessing that he was
trying to scout out a new place for them
to live but he was called back to Earth
for secret Invasion there's actually a
rising resistance on Earth who don't
want to move and instead they want to
take the planet for themselves which
will probably be the thrust of that
series Scrolls have been good in the MCU
but just like how we have good and bad
humans we also have bad Scrolls which
I'm guessing is what that show will be
about now we see a ship flying in and
huge it adds to ryanairi for putting out
this looks like the Khloe Cree ship at
the end of Captain Marvel he's done a
great breakdown of all the characters
and a recap of their backstory so if
you're forgetting what happened then
definitely check out his video and we
then see Monica in space investigating a
strange energy signature I'm not too
sure what this is but it seems to be
something that she can use her Photon
powers to tap into moniker is able to
transform herself and manipulate like
frequencies and she gets a costume
online with her comic one at the end of
the trailer the black and white design
can also be seen in those space stations
too possibly making this a uniform for
saber or a sword one of them look
someone's going to kick off either way
now this is also similar the suit that
she has in the Khan household showing
that it's all connected anyway Photon
was also called Captain Marvel at one
point in the comics and this is why the
film itself is called the Marvels who of
course have Miss Marvel 2 and there's
even potential left photo on my gain the
Captain Marvel at the end that's a big
view time neither way Photon travels out
to what's potentially a hex point which
we know are stationed throughout the
Galaxy to allow ships to war from
location and location as she goes in
closer to the one on the left you might
also notice there's one right behind
here linking up much like how the hex
points in the MCU do either way it's
busted up and the second the button
starts to use her powers we get the body
swap with Ms Marvel that's basically
setting up the premise of the entire
teaser with them constantly swapping
positions every time they use their
powers again this is likely tied
indirectly with the Nega bands which
were awarded to Captain Marvel by the
Supreme Intelligence on Earth Rick found
a matching set and upon hitting them
together the pair were able to swap
places now Kamala just has the one
bangle but we know that it has similar
Powers later on in the teaser we also
see a character busting at our own
bangle and this is none other than adult
Ben this trailer sort of hides its
villain but we know from the cast list
that she will be the one that the three
have to fight off against bit of an MCU
entanglement here are entangled well
don't don't tell Will Smith but this is
actually Zoe Ashton who just so happens
to be married to Tom Hiddleston he's of
course playing Loki so in entangle
manchoku doesn't go amiss and at one
point she fires it at Ms Marvel who
transforms in a photon before striking
back however if you look closely at a
wrist you can see that this is one of
the Bangles and that the blast comes out
of it similar to how it looked in his
Marvel these two Bangles are clearly
linked with each other and she may
potentially be attempting to get it off
Kamala so that she can stop Captain
Marvel now in the comics darben was a
crease soldier that sought to take over
the planet after ousting its leader I
think that's very much the case yeah and
darben may have killed the Supreme
intelligence in order to gain rule over
Hala at one point we see her carrying
ronan's Hammer so she's likely been
involved with the higher ups this was
actually destroyed during the Guardians
movie so it may be together like Monier
or be a spare version of it we're still
unsure exactly what happened to Haller
after the events of Captain Marvel but
it's possible that she went on to
destroy the government and also the
infrastructure had the Supreme
intelligence still been a thing then we
likely wouldn't have got darpen now
there are rumors around the film that
Carol will actually be known as the
annihilator and that she destroyed Hara
and the Supreme intelligence along with
most of the government the star Ben is
very much a good guy in the eyes of her
people let's try to bring down the
destroyer of that planet and right the
wrongs of the past it's an interesting
way to take things and maybe Dar Ben can
finally unite all of Brie Larson haters
to come together for this movie we'll
see but back to the start and after the
switch out we'll reintroduced to Ms
Marvel who believes she's part of an
Avengers test in a nice little detail
you might notice that on Nick Fury's
desk that you can catch the page you use
at the end of infinity War also beside
that there's what looks like it might be
an eye in a case and maybe he's got a
fake one that he puts on when he's out
with the ladies either way we see what
happened with with Monica and Shia soft
comes crashing down from what looks like
a damaged hex point it's important to
bear in mind that the three are swapping
places with an extra long so when this
is going on I'm guessing Carol's going
to kamala's room whilst Kamala goes in
place of Monica it's possible that we
are actually seeing where kamalo went to
during the post credit scene of Ms
Marvel as we were kind of left
dumbfounded over exactly where she went
now at this point she's attacked by Cree
Warriors who looks similar to how they
were depicted in The Miz minutes PSA
during the start of Loki it's possible
that this might even be the same Planet
as that and that could also explain why
the hex points are so damaged it's also
important to bear in mind that the
crease signed a treaty with sandar and
Guardians of the Galaxy and this ended A
Hundred Years War the Wayside itself may
also actually be Hala and since it's
been over 30 years since the events of
Captain Marvel the place might be messed
up anyway we see her go to use her
powers which is when we cut to Carol
busting through Ms Marvel's cupboard
door she's trapped in the super Stan's
room and we of course have all the
posters up with a podcast that she's
making on her computer she also has an
Iron Man toy in the dresser on the ride
and right next to the PC we can catch a
homemade helmet this scene was of course
shown in full during the credits of Ms
Marvel I'm guessing that the whole thing
is just being pulled across similar how
we got Loki season 2 at the end of
quantum Mania we can't catch the cover
of Captain Marvel Vol 7 as well and also
another two Avengers con from episode 1
in the series sloth baby Productions was
the name of her YouTube channel as well
and we could also see slots studded
about amongst the pictures Carol even
sees sketches of Kamala and Carol
hugging with a sign that says Kamala and
Carol save the world make it happen
below I got a room full of your posters
and your pictures man should call her
Kamala Stan
anyway if you're liking the video mate
gonna need a favor first off can I lend
50p and second can you also like the
video make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day you son
of a
yeah all right we're looking for Kamala
Khan
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
no I'm not again
hi where's our doctor wherever you were
[Music]
anyway from here we go to the Marvel
Studios logo which has Moon Knight and
She-Hulk in it not sure if they were
brought across to quantumania because I
haven't rewatched it but let me know
below if you know anyway to fit in with
the body swap idea we see is the two
words are now in opposite places before
they swap back next we cut a New Jersey
and is kamalakon is from Jersey City we
once more travel to her home to see her
dad opening up the door weirdly there's
a guy down the bottom with a gag over
his mouth tied up in Chains sat in a
chair not sure how this is but maybe he
was robbing the place and Captain Marvel
stopped him or some should be
arresting the dad if any if you've seen
those headlines mate and uh Kamala is
wearing the suit that she got at the end
of the series and we then see her
sitting down with a tablet in her hands
this has her full ID and profile on it
so I'm guessing that this is basically
from Fury telling her he knows
everything about her you might notice
that the house is pretty bussed up at
this point as well with someone clearly
punching through a pillar again I'm
thinking this is Captain Marvel and she
then swap back to Kamala who we saw the
aftermath of it with now it may also be
Photon and in the following shot we see
her almost getting stabbed by Chris stun
stick however she phases out before it
catches her and the guy tied up might
even be a Cree Warrior who's been
carrying this out when she explains her
power she's also getting held up by a
Cree with his suit on possibly meaning
that when she warps she pulls this one
across Kamala is also wearing some retro
Captain Marvel covers on her t-shirt and
the one on the right looks like it's
Captain Marvel 18. at this point Kamala
goes to show off her powers which is
when she switches places with Carol as
for Kamala she's now on a cruise ship
not too dissimilar to where the finale
of Captain Marvel took place joined by
Goose we see the flirkin going in full
action mode gobbling up the cree like it
did in that first film later on we see a
full flock of them looking like adorable
kittens running down the stairs careful
low mate they'll scratch your eye out
and from here we get a shot of the three
traveling through space as long as they
are together it doesn't matter too much
if they swap places as they'll be in a
similar sort of area you might also
notice Monica is wearing a green flight
jacket and this is not too dissimilar to
what her mother wore on the first film
anyway at one point they travel through
another hex point and land out what
looks like the fanciest seaside resort
this side of South Shields what you mean
it's been voted one of the top five
worst places in England that's where I
bloody love you
anyway according to the plot leaks this
is the planet alad now which pulls from
the comics the leaks actually say that
on aladdinary Carol actually ended up
marrying someone and I'm guessing that
she couldn't wait to get a Ladner anyway
later on we see what appears to be this
wedding ceremony and I think it's going
to be a pretty funny planet to visit
feels like an Indian wedding with all
the dancing and celebrations and if you
look at the crowd shot you can see Carol
Monica and Kamala standing there Kamala
is wearing the same t-shirt that she has
on the ship making me think that it
builds right off the back of that the
ship looks like it's gonna be a big
location too with us getting Kamala
running around a crease Soldier if you
look closely at her feet you'll see that
she creates platforms to run on which is
a power that she developed during the
Disney Plus show next we cut to a sky
shot and see Photon racing to catch up
with Kamala as she plummets through the
air this looks like it's just above
Jersey City so potentially Carol went to
fly out to get Kamala back after she
walked into her parents home they send
swap their places with Kamala returning
to where Carl was just above Jersey City
[Music]
we're a team no no no we're not we're
not a team
[Music]
yeah
Nick Fury then says Shields up because
Shields up in the air in space and from
here we cut to park SEO June and now we
don't know who this character is it's
theorized he's playing no bar Park's
face comes up when you Google that
character so I'm guessing that they
might be one in the same though that
could be a misdirect either way Novar is
a Cree super soldier who may have been
brought in to take on Carol due to her
having enhanced abilities we then see a
flock of flirkins roaming down the
stairs and these kittens are no doubt
gonna cause Havoc now from here we get
the shot of the three together and you
might also notice that Carol's got a new
costume too this is more in line with
one of her earlier comic looks without
being a largest star in the middle of it
you also see the fight with darpen
leading to Carl attacking her with a
Cree weapon whilst the other two are
swapping places with each other
beforehand this is done in order to
avoid attacks yeah though Carol doesn't
want to swap places which is why she's
grabbed this staff instead of just
blasting her really nice detail I think
is gonna add a lot to this Freaky Friday
fight scene anyway we end with a three
on the ship just a bit of banter
light-hearted joke to end the video with
to the right we can see a bed and this
says green Cree architecture on it so
perhaps they stole the ship that Kamala
warps too early on we can also see a
suitcase over the back of her shoulder
this does look similar to what the
Tesseract was kept in anyway that ends
the teaser and though it's kind of
getting slayed online I'm in the camp
that thinks it looks good
oh brother this guy stinks I love the
use of Intergalactic and this has a nice
fun Guardians feel to it obviously
that's one of the mcu's most successful
movies so it makes sense how they try
and recapture that anyway that closes
out the trailer and if you enjoyed it if
you didn't then let me know below we are
in competition right now giving away the
Superman 4K box set of three subscribers
on the 15th of April all you have to do
be when the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
you bake the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one screen right now tip that to
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want to see our original
reaction to the trailer or first
thoughts and definitely go ahead over to
that video right after this linked on
screen now and if you want something
else to watch that's not that then we've
got one of the Mandalorian linked on
screen too obviously I see you over
there and without the way I've been Paul
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace